[音楽]
シャイニートレジャー100ボックス
ゲットだぜこんにちははじめ社長です皆
さん2023年のポケモンカードの最後の
パックシャイニートレジャーがついに発売
されましたおめでとうござい
ますいやすごいパック出ましたねこれ
サイニートレジャーEXっていうポケカの
箱が出たんですけどもま2023年今年の
最後のパックということで今までも強い
カードだったりもう人気のポケモンとか
めっちゃ強い方が超たくさん入ってるん
ですよさらにこれ色違いのポケモンが入っ
てたりも大人気のカードなんじのそかも
入ってるっていうもうすごい開けてるだけ
で楽しいパックシャニートレザーEXが
発売したんですけれど
も僕権力を利用して100ボックス買
ちゃいまし
た嘘です嘘ですはい嘘ですそんなことし
ませんもう恒例なんですけどもこれ全部僕
のじゃないです今回ですねシャイニー
トレジャーを買うことができたポケカ
プレイヤー99人に集まってもらって俺も
一緒に混ざって100人で1人1ボックス
持ってきてもらって合計100ボックスを
みんなで開けていきたいと思いますすご
いっすよこれはもうさすがに人気の
ボックスだからたくさん販売はされてると
思うんですけどもなかなか1人で100
ボックスっていうのは手に入らないし皆
さんも手に入れられないと思うのでこの
動画を見て是非シャイニートレジャーを
100開ける感覚を味わってください
そして気になる封入率めちゃくちゃ今回
あのSRSR枠っていうこの箱に1枚運が
良くれば2枚入ってるんですけども1枚
すごいキラキラしてるカードが入ってるん
ですけどなんかねSRもすごい種類が多い
のでどのカードがどれぐらい入ってるかて
すごい気になると思うんですよでね多分
わかんないけど目玉のカードがきっとナジ
ものSARめっちゃ可愛いやつリザードン
の色違い黒いリザードンの
テラスルアナで果たしてこの中から何枚
出るのかでねなんか俺はパッと見て個人的
な感想ですけどま僕がパッと見ててわこれ
当たったらちょっとなていうカードがえ
ジャッジマンジャッジマンおじさんなん
ですよおじさん昔からあるカードだしこれ
出たらちょっとなってあの思っちゃいます
果たして100箱上げたら何がどれだけ
出るのかま年末最後なのでしっかりと
ちょっと真面目に心を整えつつ今年最後の
パック回復楽しんでいきたいと思いますで
は行きましょう
お
[音楽]
いいつ構えだでは行き
ましょう
ペリペリ
開封いいかお前らシャイニートレジャー
EXは10パックしか
ねえ少ねえから気合入れていく
ぞ1泊
[音楽]
[拍手]
目
すぐ出たらちょっとやだ
なおいきなり来たものがいるな
おあすごいすごい
すごいあ俺はだめだオじゃないSR枠た
もの1パックですね1パック目からすごい
量のSRが出ている何人出てるん
だろうSR出た
もの
[音楽]
123456789101112十分の1
超えてるけども記念すべき第1号ですす
おすお願いし
ますさ1発
目
怖い緊張
する
あでもどうですかはいよかったですはい
ウニバルEX
[拍手]
SSRいい
な
おフロル
[拍手]
SSRいやこれマジで金座する10パック
しかないからさ本におお願いします
[音楽]
ます
お鉄の和TX
SSRナジリザードンが目立ってるだけで
他のSRめちゃくちゃ多いんだよSR枠は
おすいい来てる
ねお
[音楽]
SSR
お
おおカルデアの学生
SRお
すわあいじゃないすかマスカーニEX
SSRらしいおお願いし
ますああ
ルルEX
URかこいいのよ今回のURはなんか未来
と良かった素材がすごい綺麗て美しいん
ですよいやおめでとうございますあ素敵な
カード
ですわあ
かっけリクラゲEX
SSRクラゲのSSRどどしくてかっこ
いいんだよねおす
おすおおパルデアの学生
SR絵柄が違うバイオレットの方ですね
可愛いコすお願いし
ますおおかけ
コラドいやかっこよ
お
おお偉大なキバEX
SSRお
どおおビル
EX
気づきましたか皆さんサニートレジャー
めっちゃ種類多いんですこれだからさ
ちょっと何者も出ないとかあるよ本当に
ジルが
かぶり鉄のわもかぶって
いるこのままだと全種類
で頑張っていきましょう2パク目
おかっこ
よ来い来い来い
来い可愛い
ルカリオオスの人はい
12345678910人かなおすおすお
願いし
[音楽]
ます
わあめっちゃいいんじゃないすかイギン5
EX
SSRおす
おす
おお連2連続来ました
キリコす
す
おわ可愛いいパルディアEX
[音楽]
SSRおす
おすキラフルEX
SSR
すごい隣同士で隣同士で当たりましたおす
おし
[音楽]
ますジャマン
SR
[音楽]
ありがとうござい
ますおめでとうございます強いカードなの
で大丈夫ですお願いしますお願
[音楽]
ます
おおフォレトスEX
SSRおすおすお願いしますお願いし
[音楽]
ます
来い
[音楽]
来いなんじゃも
S
[拍手]
[音楽]
出たね
初めて実物見るいやかっこよこんなポップ
なんねいやおめでとうございます
すごいこのビッグウェーブにもみんなで
乗るしかねえな
おすおピジョットEX
[拍手]
S
おクエスパトラEX
SSRおす
おすフデEX
SSR出ちゃったねみんなな者も出た
ぞ
あとは何が見たいんだろうなやっぱ
リザードは見たいですね3パク
目すごい出るんだなんじ
も
え者も欲しい当てましょう
おおパルディアの確定で
[音楽]
た
うわめっちゃ
いいめっちゃいいって出
てる
SSRの色違いは水色です
[音楽]
おおおパルディアの確定
SRお
おすわいいすねEX
SSR
おしおお可愛いグリンEX
おしあいすねリンコEX
SSRおす
[音楽]
すおクスパドライX
SSRおす
おすディEX
SSR
[音楽]
おおおかっけEX
URいいなかっけ
おベニルEX
[拍手]
グリーンEX
エンシ
フーディン多いなフーディEX
SSRおす
[音楽]
おす
[拍手]
[音楽]
SSR2枚出
たすげえ1パックに2枚出てもう1枚がニ
exsar
[音楽]
すごいありがとうございます2枚いや2枚
出る4パ
[音楽]
目
アートレア出ましたえおハートレアが出
まし
た海トリオ海トリオでし
た
もうもう出たの2枚箱出まし
[音楽]
た
10枚パック出ました10枚
パック10枚出まし
た色々大きすぎててすごいな今僕がえ2枚
箱2枚箱2枚箱出まし
たすごい今回色々きすぎてる2箱2人2
箱がもう1人出まし
[拍手]
たやばい忙しいぞ今何が起きた2枚箱2枚
箱そんな出るプルじゃめっちゃ2枚箱でる
今何が起きました僕がアートレア出て
色違い10枚パック出てえっと2枚箱が4
人めちゃくちゃおす
おす
フレドEXSSR
おおす2枚箱
ですおお綺麗E
UR
おニバルEX
SSR
おすスパトラEX
おおクラゲEX
SSR
枚
ですちょっと
[拍手]
SSR待って待ってトリア出てん
ミッキすごい
な
おおかっこよ
ミドめっちゃかっこいいかっこ
いい良かったねかっこいいなの
おすジョットEX
SSRおす
おし
おおEUEX
URおす
おすうわあめっちゃいいサーナイトEX
SSRのがいいんですよね色がおす
おす
うわあいいな欲しい隣同士で当たります
おしメEX
[拍手]
SSRあ
あちょっと待ってくださいやばいすやば
いすやばいっすやばいすどうしましたどう
しましたやばいっ
す
お
おなんじゃ
[拍手]
[音楽]
もせおうござい
ますやばいす1パックから2枚出てその
うちの1枚がなじっていうそんなことある
んだじゃ苦が重いんですけどお願いし
ますなんじゃプクリンEX
SSおす
おおおカルデアの学生
SRお
おすおおハルアの学生
Sおす
おす
ああ肉クラゲEX
S2枚まですおす
おすハデの学生
SRなんかすごい多いねパルデの学おすお
おおキンゴEX
[拍手]
SSRスよろしくお願いします
ス本当にボス引いてるじゃないです
かEX
SSRでは色違いパック出た方がいるので
見ていきましょうおすおお願いし
ますういうのあるんだよな全部色違いうわ
ARのですミミッキュARスタート
です
ヤド
ケンタロス
山エテ
おハピ
ボッチ
巨
[拍手]
キリスパトラEX
SSRばEX
SSR5パック
目え俺も出したい俺も出したいいい
の違う
な
パイナ2枚
箱ピカチュウのましたの
ピカチュ
おめでとうございますありがとうござい
ますおつ
[音楽]
おつフロルEX
SSRすごそこ全員おすおす
おす
おお
お青EX
UR
おおリEXSSR
[音楽]
わいいなサーナイトEX
SSRなきEX
Sおす
[音楽]
おすおお急に勢力を上げてきました福EX
SSR
[音楽]
おすお鉄のGX
SSR
[音楽]
おさるクスパトライX
SSR
お鉄のTX
おす
ペあ違JX
URデアの学生
[音楽]
SRリザードンEX
SSですねいやこれかっこいいんだよなお
めでとうございますざいます
[音楽]
おすマジすか2連続ですザーノEX
SSR
[音楽]
コEX
SSR
スパトラEX
SSR皆さん半分まで来ましたお疲れ様
です今のところですねイリコEXクエス
パトラEXパルデの学生のスカレットが6
枚ずつ出て
ますそこをちょっと抑えつつリザードン
EXのSARみんなで見ましょう残り5
パック頑張っていく
ぞ6パック
目
[音楽]
まだ来ないス2枚箱違2枚箱えっとちょ
えっと情報整理させてください2枚箱2枚
箱2枚箱2枚箱2枚箱2枚
[音楽]
箱そして
えっと全部色違い
パック
お
おおおジトE
SSR
おおお人EX
お怖いなサーナイトEX
SSR
おす
ンマEX
SSR
[音楽]
メニルEX
[拍手]
SSRスパトラ
SSRおす
おすEX
UR
おす
おす勝
だで
も
うわすげえネルケ
SARすごいねイラストがなんかあんまり
ポケカなかった絵のタッチこれもねなんか
なんか勝つ高かった気がするいや素敵な
カードおめでとうございますございます
いいなおし
おし鉄のまTX
[拍手]
SRおフデEX
SSR
[音楽]
おす
おわ2EX
SSRお
おおおメルケ
SR初だね多分初おおそろそろリザードン
見たいんじゃないの
[音楽]
みんな
ボス
なんかキロルEX
SSR
[音楽]
おンマンEX
SSR2枚箱2枚箱色違い
すごいな2枚箱色違いパックですお願いし
ますいいなもうミミッキュの時点で
ハッピーだよ
なキュフア
ライド
マルマイン
ラフレシアベル
カモナルトスいいな
ミニリザードン
exssさらに続き
[音楽]
ますナEX
SS
やばいやば
すぎる
やば
やばい環境みたいなことあるめちゃ震
ちゃうパックからリザードンサナトミュや
おめでとうござい
ます7パック
目そろそろ出てくれ俺
まだ出ない2枚箱2箱2枚箱2枚箱の人
552枚箱え2枚箱2枚箱2枚箱君も何
ちょっと待ってどういうことみんな2枚箱
2枚箱2箱2箱2箱2箱2箱2箱2
箱えもう普通や2枚箱
おすEX
SSR願します可愛いカルデアEX
SSR枚出た2枚出た枚裏に
もやる40exs
URお願し
ます
キラフロルEX
SSRおすおすお願いし
[音楽]
ますちょちょちょちょキラフロルEX
SSRやばいキラフロルの波が来てるぞ
おすちゃもちゃなんちゃもなんちゃもああ
くいあのの違いだ次
だちょちょちょちょちょえちょっと
ちょっと待って回ちょっと1回1回1回
あの入れ入れるか入れようか入れよう
かこ入れようねびっくりしちゃうよな急に
こんなでななんじゃ燃て
[音楽]
[拍手]
やすごい
ね
おとおめでとうござい
[音楽]
ますいやすごいな彼直前になん者も怖いっ
て言ってた
からトEX
SSR
おす
[音楽]
ジャジ
おす
マジMU
SARな
すす
鉄のわEX
SSR
おすレトスEX
SSRおお願いしますフリエ
SSRじゃあ何者も当てた方です次の狙い
はやっぱリザードリザードお願いし
ますわ全てでかいなマスカーEX
SSますでかい2枚箱でこの当たりをこれ
はけおめでとうございますありがとう
ございますおすおすお願いし
ますレトEX
SSRおすおすお願いし
ますネモ
SR
すすEX
SSRおす
おすEX
SSRおすお願いします
おアルアの学生
SR
おす左なきバイア
SSR俺出てないんだけどまだ8パ
目そろそろ
出る
ちょっと待ってこれ俺わかんないちょっと
あんまり見たくないなもオスの
人
おす2枚目この
人2枚
[音楽]
箱オンマ
exss
[音楽]
おコEX
[拍手]
[音楽]
SSR
す
ザードEX
[拍手]
SSR
SSRてルケ
SR
おデアの学生
ネEX
SSR
これであとは俺だけ
[音楽]
か見せやり
ましょう行き
[拍手]
[音楽]
ます
ジバルEX
[拍手]
SSR
す9パ
[音楽]
目全員2枚箱なの2枚箱なの2枚箱の
人えぐいえぐいえぐいって2枚箱2枚箱2
枚箱22枚2枚2枚2
枚お
お
ビル
URおす
おメル
ケス
おすおじゃないですかスターナイトEX
SRごます
おしラフロEX
SSRすお願いし
ます
[拍手]
さ2枚パックです
てからのげるやばいな結構ミューも出て
ますねいやおめでとうござい
ます
おカルデアのEX
SSR
おデアの醒
SR
サナトEX
SSRボス
ボスサーナイトEX
[音楽]
S
ラジで
ターナEXのタも出てなかったので初です
おめでとうござい
[音楽]
ますおす
おす偉大なきEX
SSR
おすラフロEX
みんなラスト1パックだ大変悲しいことに
出てないカードがたくさん
ある誰かリザードン出してくれちなみに
まだSR枠出てないよって人います
かああおめでとうございますあなたたちは
SR確定なので1泊持って先にステージの
上で待ってて
くださいラスト10パック
目2箱2箱22箱2箱2箱2箱2箱箱2
箱2枚
箱2枚箱枚箱枚そっかそっかてか全員2枚
箱だわ
ここ10枚もうこれみんな2枚箱ですから
ね俺と
[拍手]
SSR出してくれ
そっち
ですザEX
SSRPUEX
[拍手]
URわめっちゃかけライEX
UR
イリコEX
SSR
おす大EX
スパトラ
SRでは色違いパック行きましょう
おグの
アウレア星ガ
可愛い
フートンラギング
[音楽]
こた
な
[音楽]
ルカリオのの
クラゲニバEX
SSR
そしてS
さんそして
ラストカルデアドEX
Sこれでもう座ってる皆さんは終了っって
ことですねお疲れ様でした行き
[音楽]
ます
[拍手]
ごめんでは最後のSR枠この5名に開けて
もらおうと思いますよろしくお願いし
ますは1人ってきまし
む
ではお願いし
ます
SSお願いし
当たり確定みたいな感じになってます
けど
EXお願いし
ますお願いし
[音楽]
ます
スパ
タやばい出ないではお願いします願し
ますサーナイトEX
SRおうございます
あうござい
[音楽]
ますあのためにDJさんに曲を準備して
もらっ
て少年の演出も全部準備知ってるんです
ねお願いし
ますではお願いし
ます
マカ
[音楽]
S
he
てなる予でし
[音楽]
た皆さんお疲れ様でし
[拍手]
たござい
では開封結果に移りますシャイニー
トレジャーを100箱上げた結果動画では
取り上げなかったんですけどもアートレア
イラスト違いのカードがめちゃくちゃたに
入ってるらしいんですけども100箱
中14枚でし
ためちゃくちゃ少ない10箱買って1枚と
かそんなレベルですミミッキュのアート
レアが6枚海トリオのアートレアが4枚
ルカマンのアートレアが3枚パモ1枚
ですえフモ当てた方おめでとうございます
唯一ですナンバーワンですおうございます
ナンバーワオンリーワンです色違いで
ピカチュウがすごいなんか可愛いというか
価値が高いよていうのを聞いていました
色違いのピカチュウが出たのが100
ボックス中2枚
ですすごいピ出た
方2人おめでとうございますレアです
そして色違いパック色違い10枚パック
全部色違いてパックが出た方
が3名ですおめでとうござい
ますそしてえ2枚箱の人の数人中2枚箱
なかなか普段出ないと思うんです
けど42箱でし
た結構出てます100人で42人が箱でし
たございますSSRから発表していきます
福林EX8枚オバEX6枚パルテアドEX
4枚フーディンEX6枚コレトEX6枚
偉大な牙EX7枚鉄のわEX5枚キラフル
EXえ11枚リクラEX3枚クエスパトラ
EX10枚ウニバルEX8枚ラボEX1枚
しか出なかった
ですだよマスカーニEX5枚ピジョット
EX4枚イきリンコEX8枚ミュEX4枚
サーナイトEX8枚リザードンEXが5枚
でした以上がSSRになり
ます結構ばらけてますね続いてSR
サポートのカードですねジャッジマン2枚
ネルケ3枚ネモ2枚パルデアの学生の
バイオレット4枚パロニアの学生
スカーレットが7枚でしたおめでとう
ござい
ますパロアの学生めちゃ続いてURあの
すごい加工のしてあるカードですEUEX
3枚オジEX2枚デルEXが5枚アジアン
EX2枚コランEX2枚ミライドEXが1
枚だけでした1枚おめでとうござい
ます続いてスペシャルアートレアSAR
ですニEXが3枚サーナイトEX1枚
ネルケあネルケはEXじゃないネルケ1枚
そしてナンジもがS3枚でしたおめでとう
ございます
すごいえここからがすごいんですけどもえ
ボタンSAR0枚ネモSAR0枚ペパー
SAR0枚リザードンEXSが0枚でし
たすごいっすよこんなに100箱開けても
出ないカードが4枚ぐらいあるんでこれは
ね本当にたくさん開けたいですね皆さん
100箱回復でお疲れ様でしたありがとう
ございまし
たよいお
を